did you know there was a college
Christmas party tonight NFI me and you
not
invited you all right yeah I've got a
flat tire take my bike hey that is so
kind thank you I'm sorry I don't know
your name I'm I'm Felix Oliver Oliver
Oliver I love you I love I love you all
right cheers
Ollie my parents they've got problems
what kind of what do you mean problems I
only think I'll ever go home again well
why don't you come home with me come to
salurn Mr Quick wow and here he is now
oh what beautiful eyes oh how wonderful
yeah I told you it wasn't a minger oh
but darling you're kind about everyone
you can't be
trusted I had them hang up an old school
dinner jacket we dressed for dinner here
dress for dinner yeah it's like it's
like black
time I think I like you even more than
last year's
one you're so um so what
real can't of being easy for Venicia I
you being a mother
why now it's time to take things up a
notch should I had them Apple Bottom
Jeans boots with the fur
this
place you know it's not for
you lots of people get lost in
salurn oh that's just giving me
goosebumps look Pamela oh
no I think you
m quiet harmless gr to shiny
things what have you doing I just
thought that maybe I could help you're
not leaving us you're not leaving
so I don't think I'll ever go home
[Applause]
again